jeannine est assistante familiale depuis
11 ans elle accueille des enfants en
situation de danger et se bat pour leur
donner une éducation mais aussi un foyer
chaleureux où l'ue peuvent s'épanouir
ils sont chez moi oui parce que bon ils
sont pas bien de la famille gens ont eu
2 malgré tant en saison après celle de
leur famille nous c'est la famille on
peut dire ça porte garant thèse mais ils
ont beaucoup de difficulté à sabrer dans
leurs familles
miley d'une grande prématurée ni après à
peine six mois de grossesse cet enfant
nécessite beaucoup de soin donc une
grande responsabilité pour jeanine et
plusieurs assistantes familiales ont
refusé de prendre ce bébé en charge
jeannine est très fier d'avoir relevé le
défi est de voir miley en pleine forme
aujourd'hui la petite de bons et les
ailes est arrivé chez nous on ira voir
savoir comment ce faire environ pas
simon 7 mois elle demande beaucoup
beaucoup de soin surtout de suivi
médical
et puis vous
elle demande aussi des beaucoup beaucoup
de présence ma présence parce que comme
ces micro-ondes prématurée cette petite
elle a besoin beaucoup d'affection être
assistante familiale c'est accueillir
temporairement un enfant ainsi elle
permet le retour de l'enfant dans sa
famille dans les meilleures conditions
possibles
c'est un relais provisoire entre
l'enfant et ses parents
la durée du séjour varie en fonction de
chaque situation
cela peut aller de quelques jours à
quelques mois ou quelques années
moi même je ne sais pas combien de temps
je vais la garder même si c'est possible
de la garder jusqu'à comme la première
car il était non je regarderai messi
s'il n'est pas en bon merci surtout les
en situation s'est améliorée
ben elle peut repartir d'un moment à
l'autre
offrir un cadre de vie chaleureux et
équilibrée à des enfants dont les
parents sont défaillants ou maltraitant
telle est la mission de l'assistante
familiale une profession que jeanine
exerce avec passion
thiam les enfants moi même j'ai eu
quatre enfants
si j'ai pas les enfants d'amande maison
je pense que je serai triste
non mais c'est vraiment un métier qui
est vraiment ok très dur qui a beaucoup
de difficulté je me dis mais c'est quand
même ça ça reste un beau métier avant
métier depuis de nombreuses années le
conseil départemental accompagne les
assistants familiaux à travers des
formations et un suivi au quotidien